come on man come on where's the [__]
Wi-Fi
do black Twitter's hilarious start by
saying
that this assertion that
come on dude
oh man I want to see this so bad yo in
the meantime leave a comment about how
shitty the [__] Wi-Fi is and we have
to fix it so like And subscribe though
and yeah I'll be in Nashville but anyway
dude why won't this [__] go dude and
I'm on the good one too on oh dude yes
it's not working right when I wanted to
[__] literally ruin the whole bit
yeah yes dude a hundred percent ruining
the bid it's still color Wheeling Yes
Man
oh dude come on work
oh my god dude it's 2023 you know that
whole thing that Louis CK said oh be
happy you're in the airplane the Wi-Fi
doesn't worry you're 30 000 feet in the
air this is unbelievable you live in an
awesome dude no don't have this [__]
until it works my Wi-Fi should be
working but it's not and if I were to
say my wife I'm working that's captain
why would it not be working right now
okay I'll go into [__] then you know
what I'll go into Safari because I
usually use Chrome if I'm brutally
honest
and I'm going to use Safari thanks for
sticking with me guys and during these
hard times
I'm pausing it on Chrome and I'm going
sitting on chrome and I'm going into the
here we go here we go into the [__]
uh what is it Safari surfing Safari yeah
oh and it's not even going it's not even
starting on Safari
I have an update I honestly haven't
updated my computer in so long I think I
have [__] birdie which is like one of
the first ones they're on like white
snow leopard now and I I literally have
[__] beetle
wow dude there's a little apple humor
for you you know what I'll tell you this
much how about the guy oh
dude please work
oh [__] yeah dude it's not working come
on
I will start by saying I like already by
the way I I'm starting it over just to
at least the the how you you can tell
how
he's trying to sell you can tell he's
trying to sound smart you can tell this
guy also has a voice with his friends
that's the best and that's as racist as
we get in this podcast I will start by
saying
that this assertion that I did not
mention the 403 argument don't worry
about that okay because it wouldn't be
it I'd have to do it anyway so okay
don't even worry about that okay okay
I'm just saying that it's just not true
it's cap to be honest but um that aside
though
my god dude
the stenographer just like this
Capital put in capital letters
I will start the way he's trying to
suppress his you know I'm saying um I so
check it out so all right so look
I agree we have all come here today you
know by saying
that some of these assertion that so I
did not mention the 403 argument don't
worry about that first time you ever
said the word assertion I'd have to do
it anyway so okay don't even worry about
that okay okay I understand that it's
just not true it's capped to be honest
um dude
he says it's not true first and then
says it's cap
the other way
you know it's just not true so let's is
capped to be honest judge uh your honor
um dude I I I can't even
somebody wrote the first thing dead ass
your honor
you left for that
you're not saying we bleed New York dog
right so like check this out judge
dead ass man
we gonna be doing a trial right and
that's that's all good that's that ain't
that you know not for nothing my man's
my man's in them he ain't do [__] all
right if you said he did that's cap
um
you know what I mean you talk about did
he do it or did he do it do it right so
the difference is right
it's like crazy dog
after after the verdict comes in guilty
shh I'll try hard your honor I don't
know what you're talking about
cap
I mean dude
how do you say that to a judge
that's the funniest [__] thing
that's just not true that's that's cap
your honor I wanna I have to listen to
it again I mean I will start by saying
that this assertion that
I did not mention the 403 argument don't
worry about that okay because it
wouldn't be it I'd have to how much is
the Lord 25 okay don't even worry about
that okay okay I understand that it's
just not true it's cap to be honest but
um that aside though I mean I'm gonna
lose
[Laughter]
oh I
I my mind this is imagine you're you're
on track for murder what is it stealing
what is it I don't [__] know
and your lawyer says to the [__]
judge your judge that's cap
you go like this
25 to life
25 to Life you get red you start getting
ready you know what I mean he's like I
gotta put my stuff in I gotta
I might get my stuff in order see what's
going on here because I'm going 25 to
Life
hold on dude
[Laughter]
the lawyer said it you're bugging with
these charges your honor
dead ass crazy crazy crazy
crazy crazy congratulations
[Music]